We heard a lot of information in the last
video, so here is just a summary of all of
that on one screen. We can think about
Grant's sales story so far as having two
situations. The situation after the first
day, which I'm going to call the before
picture and the situation after the second
day of selling, which is the present
situation we're concerned with. The last
equation that we came up with, a = 36w +
22n had to do with just the sales from the
first day. So, I changed the name of the
total money earned to a old to show that
this is the money earned after the first
day of selling. This equation still works
if we're only interested in calculating
the money that Grant earned from his
friends after just that one day, but now,
we want to find, is what I'm going to call
a new. The money he's going to get from
those people and from these new people who
also want to buy. What we're going to do
in this quiz is come up with an equation
for a new, which should combine the
information from a old with this new data
about people who are also going to buy the
wipers and nozzles. So, which of these
equations down at the bottom is the
correct equation for a new? The total
amount of money that Grent will have after
these people on the first day buy his
wipers and nozzles, and these people from
the second day buy his wipers and nozzles.
This is a lot of information to take in, so
I'm going to lable this quiz a challenge
quiz. Actually many of the quizzes that
you've had have been challenging, but I
think that this one is especially
difficult. Think really carefully about
how many terms you think this new equation
should have. Should it have two terms or
should it have four terms? Also, there may be
more than one correct answer. Even if you
don't get it right the first time, just
give it another shot.